want to go back to Joe Concha to react
about the news we mentioned just a few
minutes ago that legendary broadcaster
Barbara Walters has died at the age of
93 and Joe there is no dispute about her
impact on American culture
oh absolutely and in American journalism
for that matter Jason we talk about
liberal bias and we talk about all the
things that are wrong with media now
today in America but but there was a
time particularly back in the 70s in the
80s where Barbara Walters was a great
journalist and and one of the first a
real Trailblazer for that matter for
females within this profession as far as
anchoring before anybody else even
thought about putting a female anchor on
the air and then obviously she came up
with the idea for the view back in the
90s it's not the view that we watched
today obviously but her idea at the time
was an exchange of ideas and debate from
all sides and and she will be missed 93
years old Barbara Walters and obviously
all those great specials that we all
watch as far as the most compelling
people of the year uh again a great
journalist a great lady a Class Act and
she will be missed Jason
yeah sometimes controversial but always
probing some of the most important
interviews and in throughout the
generations